it's Jurassic Park's 30th Anniversary so
let's take a look at some deleted scenes
from the movie did you know there was a
scene where the sick Triceratops had
babies that would pester the kids and
even a moment where haman's
granddaughter Lex rides one of them this
scene was prepped and a baby animatronic
was even created for the scene but it
was ultimately cut from the film due to
pacing issues although it was cut an
entire level is based around this scene
in the Jurassic Park movie segment of
Lego Jurassic world you can get more fun
facts like this and dive deeper into the
world of Jurassic Park and Universal's
digital movie store where you can get
your very own copy of the entire
Jurassic Park series filled with tons of
behind the scenes special features and
deleted scenes celebrate the franchise's
30th anniversary by watching any of the
films on all of your devices and never
worry about losing access to your movies
or having to watch ads click the Creator
cart Link in the pinned comment to get
30 off any Jurassic Park movie or bundle
and banter to win some awesome Jurassic
Park merch